alright guys let's check out how my last
video did maybe it's still monetized ah
31 31 dollars oh oh no I'm shaking the
ad pocalypse well I'm still living in
the slum I'm sure the other video was
fine
38 top box I'm too stressed out man I
need some meditation quick open some
meditation on YouTube [ __ ] of this
spoken recording you will find yourself
encountering the 7 chakras or energy
centers in your body you will understand
what parts for your life may need a
little energy healing and you will give
your spirit exactly what you need
compassion [ __ ] gentleness I'll go and
the ability to transform into something
more beautiful than you can ever imagine
jacksepticeye I want to transform into
jacksepticeye imagine that you're
walking up a stone staircase ok that
spirals around you know if you're
stressed out you can you can do this
with us the steps are made from white
marble white marble ok continue to climb
slowly and things like a lot of expert
men
there are many steps spiralling up ahead
of you we're not afraid of height why
are you implying that I was afraid of
the height you think I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's meditation it feels
wonderful to be leaving all of your
problems below I hate walking up stairs
what the [ __ ] you are now approaching
the top stick finally Jesus Christ there
is a sudden rush of freedom feel the
well what stuff like where do you come
from did I for [ __ ] to sneak
himself into heaven what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] season you look up and
look at the heavens put his [ __ ] face
there instead of an attractive photo
look at his mouth
it's like Jason Stevenson our Lord and
Savior
Jason Stevenson will set you free you
know what that worked that did that did
make me feel a lot better
$3.00 I might as well I might as well
start sucking dick oh [ __ ] it's
happening ahead happening again bro
I need another meditation real fast yeah
since in award I seen this guy before
why have I saw he's big good maybe deep
once again we are out here baby
we're nature don't call me baby please
unless it's into private dams look like
I just sniffed me did I just get me are
you judging my smell is there something
wrong with my alright breathing in that
good off Khurana
did he just say he breathes in a pure
honor lots of people since I made that
video why you should never meditate they
realized that meditation was actually
good for them so I got a snapchat
question Ralph how do we meditate and
what's the best time to meditate we and
even had breakfast yet can I get it
hello pretty sure you can see like the
[ __ ] universe inside those nostrils
look at this dude I appreciate a brother
from another big-ass nose mother how's
it going bro can I get a Hello I
meditate every single day because I
smoke weed every single
day because you feel better you feel
better you look better well I mean
debatable you can actually start to
appreciate yourself because you never
used to did you did you honestly all
memes aside I feel like I could really
use some meditation no you didn't right
okay I guess no I guess not
oh my [ __ ] god my god oh my god oh my
god how am I supposed to meditate with
this woman in front of me
okay let's learn how to meditate
together guys hi I'm Mary yucks you're
have headphones on your left ear is
about to have an orgasmic feeling those
who don't know me I'm a den master and
this is the first video of a series that
will show you how to meditate
can you stop smiling because you freaked
him into the [ __ ] out oh gosh oh god
well that was what that [ __ ] was that
that will show you how to meditate oh my
god how's it going bros my name is
people affected by depression worldwide
it's no doubt an incredibly remote and
today we're gonna how to train your
voice we can meditate everywhere and in
two seconds two seconds why are you
walking why why are you having coffee
empty you I had a meeting so you can
meditate man if you can meditate so on
enough I wonder what else we can do so
on enough they do meditation mini king
of nothing cousin too
so push too much so we cannot block
thought and emotion intake we need
totally emotion so whether you listen to
your monkey mine or not that's the issue
what I could monkey mind - chatting
enough Paula Paula Paula yeah yeah I
want to learn how do you do the [ __ ]
to second second meditation that seems
awesome we have to make strands to Adam
ocular but how do my friend are you
telling me I could have friends
oh I didn't it is happening too fast how
to give job monkey my saw the simple
meditation tainted the aware of the
breath so you asked monkey my hello
watch breath so monkey mind yeah good
idea
and be aware of breath breathing in
trading house breathing in there's a lot
of pot come at the background don't care
no problem as long as if you're not
forgetting your breath anything is okay
that's awesome
that's so [ __ ] that's so [ __ ] cool
honestly I feel better already this is
great is I think honestly this is just
what I like oh my god didn't revenue god
damn it
Malcolm was right Malcolm [ __ ] I pulled
out the [ __ ] we're gonna have to try
something else to cure my crippling
depression
[Music]
put down the gun put down the gun okay
okay okay all right I'm sorry
wait what what did I can't [ __ ] hear
you you're wet
that's what are you saying what whatever
you say just don't say anything
[Music]
I already can't hear a single one do you
want my money cuz I'll give you money if
you stop okay okay okay how is it
supposed to be stressed I am super
stressed right now you're robbing me
please not my YouTube money I swear I
don't have any look I'm living in this
month am I the only one who feels like
this is like the start of a porno huh
what's she doing I'm not gonna kiss you
she wanted me to kiss her you know what
fine
[Music]
do you like that yeah you like that
don't tell my chest writers don't get my
jet or you want you one on the mouth you
want on the mouth with milk good from
now on I'm gonna keep living in the
slums and I don't even care about it
from now on no more talk about ABS who
gives a [ __ ] anyway from now on I'm just
going to be good old Felix again no
family-friendly required I'm just going
to be me be sure to check out my patreon
link at the description like this video
for $100 Amazon giftcard
and if you delete your channel today you
could win a free trip with Michael from
Vsauce
this has been pity pie signing on